[Music]  love's not the only thing on top Beyonce  herself got stuck atop a floating stage  set  the Queen was forced to take an  emergency ladder while performing with  hubby jay-z during their on the run to  tour stop in Poland a concert goer tells  et the singer had to get rescued after  the stage stopped working while she was  performing young forever with her  husband  Beyonce appeared to stay in good spirits  while stranded at one point she even  broke into a quick dance for the crowd  before exiting the stage it comes as no  surprise that B stayed calm and  collected this isn't the first time  she's recovered from a malfunction like  a pro from her earring ripping mid  performance during a title concert -  keeping up with sister Solange after her  Coachella wardrobe malfunction beyonce  is the ultimate professional and always  ready to give her beehive her best  [Music]